how are you doing today
how are you I love your T-shirt
I'm gonna say thank you I appreciate
that
um a bunch of questions I want to first
start with I'm very happy you got to
make the sequel It's a ton of fun I hope
it's a huge hit
um thank you you produced this and I am
curious what do you do as a producer
when your stars won't come out of their
trailer or are complaining about craft
services
oh my goodness
thank goodness I am able to work with
wonderful people
um
there is not one person on that set that
ever plays up
um luckily we work with real actors and
real professionals so um we are never
hit with that issue ever
the only big receiver is covered
that just comes in sweeps our sets
and that's the only that's the only
thing we tackled other than that no
actors were making were harmed in the
making of This film you and Henry look
like you're having so much fun working
together and uh I remember talking to
you after the first Nola you were hoping
to make a sequel now that you've made a
sequel how much are you hoping to
continue playing Enola and being able to
make another one
I mean obviously I really hope so
I love anola and I know that now people
are very much invested in the character
and the plot
and I can only hope that Netflix you
know provides that trust and
opportunity once more you've obviously
been playing 11 for a while you've now
played uh Enola you know you've been
playing two characters a lot over the
last few years and I'm curious are you
excited about the possibility of doing
when stranger things raps being able to
do all these different roles or you sort
of like gonna be incredibly sad because
it's been such a huge part of your life
it has been a huge part of my life and
it will it will be sad for the most part
but there is an inkling of me
being able to
finally let go of her and being able to
free up some of my schedule to be able
to tell some stories of my own
um you are working with the Russo
Brothers now big fan of those guys
really excited about electric State uh
what was it about that material that
said I need to do this
the fact that
they were so dead set on me playing her
just
the fact that trust in a director with
an actor it's really unheard of and I
don't really get to experience that very
often so the fact that they wanted me
um only made me want them even more and
to be able to have that opportunity to
make this movie with them has been such
an amazing experience
um and it's just been like a really good
collaborative effort you know it felt
feels like I'm actually working with I
mean real real experienced experienced
team
um their team is incredible the
directors are amazing obviously and I've
got an amazing uh cast to be alongside
last question for you you've done so
many cool shots through your your
already uh great career uh which shot
ended up being the toughest for you
whether it be because of a camera move
whether it be because of the emotional
need of the scene I'm just curious which
was the shot
yeah I did a really difficult shot just
now on electric State about last last
week it was really hard maybe one of the
hardest I've ever had to do
um I I got it
um in the end but but just very
technical
um and required a lot of uh
a lot of people a lot of time a lot of
actually in the first no I also had a
very difficult shot where I had to talk
to camera while crossing the road and
not being hit by horses and carriages
very tough
on that note I will just say
congratulations I really hope it's a
huge hit and you guys get to make
another one thanks Steve I appreciate it
cool have a great day